familiar with charlie sheen the actor
yeah i've heard of him okay
um you know he used to date a couple
porn stars i heard that brie olson i
believe was one of them i don't know the
other one do you know
i remember he was one of his vixens but
now he's uh getting into a lot of heat
with his wife or ex-wife denise richards
remember her from
um multiple movies um but apparently
here's the story and i want to get your
thoughts on the other side of this so
charlie sheen blames his ex-wife denise
richards after his daughter
joins only fans and says quote unquote
it's because she's living with her
mother charlie sheen isn't happy that
his daughter
her name is sammy signed up for only fan
she's 18 years old by the way she's 18
and now lives with her mother this did
not occur under my roof by the way
charlie sheen was a human wrecking ball
what was he uh winning that was he's
known for um he said i do not condone
this but since i'm unable to prevent it
i urge her to keep it classy creative
and not sacrifice
her integrity
um
he goes on to say denise seemingly claps
back saying this is now denise saying
sammy's 18 and this decision wasn't
based on whose house she lives in she
however remains supportive of her
daughter all i want all i can do as a
parent is guide her and trust her
judgment
but she makes her own choices so you got
um
charlie sheen
famous actor denise richards
famous actress daughter 18 sammy
doing only fans lovely girl
um but he says that he does not want her
sacrificing her integrity if you could
speak to charlie sheen who made this
quote is doing only fans or this type of
adult work sacrificing your integrity do
we know this is actually a quote this is
actually the quote yes
and we there's a lot of media stuff that
isn't yeah that's what i'm about this is
a really nobody's actually saying i know
what it's a real story i've seen this
already
that
he said i urge her to keep it classy
creative and not sacrifice her integrity
so do you think she's sacrificing her
integrity so this is what i have to say
so he's not wrong in being a father and
saying all those things
the problem that i have is that
congested with anything and if i was a
parent i don't know if i would
definitely defer what he says but
only fans isn't only a sexual platform
the adult entertainment made that
platform what it was and it was popular
before the pandemic when the pandemic
started it gave other people an avenue
to create money to be content creators
so there's people on there that do
workout videos cooking videos all kinds
of things like pictures like that
picture she that was on there she has it
on instagram i'm sure that's something
that people every day she's not showing
anything whatever so if you're sending
me that already on instagram and you can
make money off of it why not i think
only fans gets a bad rep because there's
adult entertainment on it again on
myself i'm not doing sex scenes with
other people like them doing other
things there's a way different avenues
and things that i feel like people kind
of misinterpret really what only fans is
it's a platform for creators to create
whatever kind of lane you want to
if i was a per you know like in the
situation where that was my daughter
obviously i'm gonna have reservations
because you don't know what's on it and
you don't want to go on it and see
what's on it because you don't know what
she's doing so i think his quote is is
correct if you had a younger sister 18
years old let's say and she said hey
alexis i'm thinking about doing only
fans or even porn at the end of the day
nobody's going nobody could have stopped
me at 21 years old i didn't ask anybody
i didn't ask even my family whatever i
wanted the approval because i didn't
want to be shunned from my family and
did this whatever but at that age
look at even with you or that no one
could tell you no you're gonna do what
you want to do so you either support it
and you be a part of your kid's life or
you don't and they make the options that
you may not be a part of their life
but do but
would you look at yourself now knowing
what you know
going back or telling your sister
would you tell her some of the pitfalls
or some of the things to look out for i
definitely would tell her you know give
her advice but for me like i in my
career personally not everybody is the
same way i have no i haven't had a bad
situations happen to me i think there's
growth or whatever but i don't i had a
great career but i know that many women
don't like lana and uh what's her name
the
one who did she was like a paralegal
mia khalifa
again some people get in the business
for different reasons some people do
whatever i you know i wasn't that way
like i
for me i said like sex is like art to me
it's how i express myself i've always
felt comfortable naked i never like i
just owned my sexuality in that sense
so i was just i did what i wanted to do
some people feel or fall into like
situations where they're told what to do
that wasn't my scenario so i can't speak
on that but i have heard stories and i
had heard those things so if it was
someone that was in my immediate circle
or asking for advice i definitely would
give advice on all levels but i wouldn't
i would let them do and make the choice
that they wanted to make i wouldn't
deter on whatever level because at the
end of the day you're still going to do
what you want to do
mm-hmm
is that what your podcast is too is that
you guys talk or you talk about
the industry and stuff like that so my
podcast is private talk with alexis
texas i have a regular episode which is
like lifestyle entertainment that i have
everybody from people like yourselves
from entertainment people to social
media people and then i have a private
talk after dark so here we're here this
weekend in miami to do the exotica
convention and i'm doing the after dark
episodes which is with people who are in
the adult entertainment industry who
have only fans and things like that and
so we speak about um
stuff on scenes how they got into the
business how you know their stories if
that you know if it's good bad or
indifferent and then we know we play a
game called truth of texas that i made
up and we do kind of a games of like
getting to know people a little bit more
intimately on levels that it's not
questions like oh what's your favorite
sex position what's you know more in
depth um so it's the versatility of both
um but yeah it's lifestyle entertainment
okay
um by the way if there's anything we
take in from alexis she owns her [ __ ]
yeah she's not backing down she's not
apologizing i love it i live not living
with regret so the haters are going to
hate but alexis is going to do what
she's got to do doing something right if
there's hating so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire sauce cast
click right here
you